PROFESSOR: Welcome
to this recitation
on the phase portrait.
So you're given matrix A, a
two-by-two matrix with entries
minus 1, minus 1,
1 minus c, where
c is a constant we will
be varying, and minus 1.
As c increases from 0 to
other positive values,
determine the path of the
system on the trace-determinant
diagram that we saw in
previous recitations
and draw the phase
portraits that
corresponds to the critical
points and the nature
of the critical points.
So here, we're basically
talking of a system that
would be a two-by-two system
where we have derivatives
of entries x, y for vector,
equals to this matrix, A_c,
multiplying the
unknown vector x_c.
So take a few minutes and
work out through this problem
and I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So I already prepared the
trace-determinant diagram
for you.
So here as a reminder,
this is the parabola
that determines whether
we're going to have
repeated eigenvalues or not.
Above this parabola, we have two
complex conjugate eigenvalues.
Below this parabola, we have
real eigenvalues, either
of the same signs,
positive or negative,
or of different signs.
And then, we have
the borderline cases.
In our case here, we're
looking in a matrix A
with the trace equals to minus
1 minus 1, so it's minus 2,
and a determinant that
is equal to 2 minus c.
So here, we are basically
along this dotted line
where the trace
equals to minus 2.
So either we're going
to have complex values
with negative real parts
or negative eigenvalues.
So we're in stable
configurations.
So we're going to be
moving at c equal to 0
from a case where-- I'm just
going to label this point 1.
For example, we have the
matrix, minus 1, 1, 1, minus 1
with the trace
equals to minus 2,
and the determinant equals to 2.
So clearly, we are this point.
And we are just going to be
increasing the value of c
and moving along these lines,
crossing this first boundary
case where we will have
either defective or not case.
And I'll discuss very
briefly what we have.
And then, we have other
value where we are basically
in this area where we have
real eigenvalues, both of them
negative, so we have stability.
And it would
basically be a sink.
And then we cross this
other borderline case
where the determinant
is equal to 0.
And here, we have one eigenvalue
that is equal to 0 and one
that is negative.
And then, we get to do
the part of the diagram
where the determinant
is negative,
and the trace is negative.
And we basically have
a saddle structure
where we have one
eigenvalue as negative
and another eigenvalue
that is positive.
So let's get through
these five cases.
And I'll just do more
detailed picture illustrating
what I just said.
So just write down a bit more
in detail the first case here.
So we have the case
where the eigenvalues are
both complex
conjugate, and we have
their real part being negative.
So basically, we have spirals,
asymptotically stable spirals.
And the spirals could be either
clockwise or counterclockwise.
And one way of determining
the direction of these spirals
is to look at the
sign of the velocity
vector of the trajectories
in the phase space.
So the phase space
basically diagram here
where we have x and y as
the axes of this space.
So let's look, for example, at
a particular point here that
would be velocity vector [1, 0].
And this position vector [1, 0]
would give us a velocity vector
of minus 1 and plus 1.
So basically, this vector
would be directed upward,
which means that we are in
the case where we would have
a spiral coming this way
toward the critical point
and basically with the velocity
vector here going this way.
You don't have to
actually do all this
to figure out which direction
of the spiral you should choose.
You can just look-- for these
cases, two-by-two matrices--
at the entry at the lower
left part of your matrix.
And if the coefficient
here is positive,
then it will determine the
direction of the velocity
vector at this point.
So if it's positive
in this case,
you would have this
counterclockwise direction
of rotation of the spiral.
So now we can move on and do the
following cases a bit faster.
So the second case, we are
in the case where we now
have two repeated eigenvalues.
Both of them are negative.
So we can have either
a complete case.
If we had a matrix
that was diagonal,
we would have basically a star.
But that's not the case,
because if we pick, for example,
the value c equals to 1 that
puts us on the parabola,
we can see that the matrix
A_c is not diagonal.
So we are in a defective case.
The defective case, if you
compute the eigenvalues
and eigenvector would give you
something that looks like that.
The first ray of the
eigenvector corresponding
to your eigenvalues would be
in the direction of [1, 0].
We have negative eigenvalues,
so it's going to 0.
And basically, to
determine the direction,
you have to see that we are
also following a transition here
on the trace-determinant
diagram.
And so basically, we
will have a spiral
that would look like this.
What am I doing?
Am I doing the same thing?
And it would basically
rotate, as you can see here,
in the same direction as the
case that we had just before.
Because we basically have the
transition of the structure
of the critical point.
And the arrows are pointing
toward the critical point
again, because our two
eigenvalues are basically
here negative.
It is just a repeated
eigenvalue that is negative.
So now we can move
on to a third case
where here we move
into the wedge area
where we have the two
eigenvalues now being real,
and both of them are negative.
So for example, we would
have two eigenvalues that
would give us two eigenvectors
that are basically,
they're rays.
The direction of the
trajectories on these two rays
would be toward
the critical point,
because we have, again,
negative eigenvalues.
And the trajectories then
would be following the lambda.
So if I, for example, pick
lambda_1 less than lambda_2,
then I would have something
like this going to 0.
And we would have this
trajectory corresponding
to the eigenvalue
that is closer to 0.
And again, the
arrows would be going
toward this critical point.
So we can now move on.
And if we keep increasing
c, we reach now the point
4 where we are in
the special case,
again, a boundary case
where the determinant is 0.
But the trace is non-zero.
If the determinant is 0, which
is the product of the two
eigenvalues, it means that
we have one eigenvalue that
is equal to 0 and another
eigenvalue that is actually,
in this case, minus
2, so just negative.
So what happens here?
What happens is that we
have now the eigenvector
that corresponds to the
eigenvalue equals to 0
is basically just defining a
whole line of critical points.
So all the points
on this line that
would correspond, so
for example, to lambda 0
are all critical points.
So we don't need to
actually draw arrows here.
All the points would
be critical points.
And another direction
or ray would
be determined by the second
eigenvalue, lambda_2.
And we would have, for example,
directions in this way.
It would correspond to
the direction of v_2.
So all these would
be parallel to v_2.
And we would have
the trajectories
going toward all the
critical points on this line.
So in this case, we're in
a case where we actually
don't have one
localized critical point
like in the previous
case that we saw.
We've actually have a whole
line of critical points.
So let's move one
more point down.
So here, another
value of c, we now
are in the lower
part of the diagram
where we now have
two eigenvalues that
are again real.
But now, the
determinant is negative.
Determinant is the
product of the two.
So basically we know
that one is positive
and the other one is negative.
So for example here, we
would have one positive,
the negative eigenvalue.
So we would have the
positive eigenvalue
and the negative
eigenvalue here.
So here, again, we're just
moving in the structure
of the critical point.
So we should have a smooth
transition between the diagrams
going 1 to 5.
And so here, what we
see is that we actually
have the ray that is basically
the stable space here
that would give us the
trajectories going to 0.
But it's the only region
where we have stability.
And all the trajectories
will just then
be tangent in minus
infinity to the ray v_1,
corresponding to the
negative eigenvalue,
and going towards the
direction of the ray
with a positive eigenvalue
at plus infinity.
So we would have
something like that, that
would correspond to a saddle.
This would be a comb.
This is basically a sink
or basically a stable node.
This would be
defective stable node.
And here, we just have a
asymptotically stable spiral.
So basically here
what you could see
is that we have,
by just changing
the value of the constant
c, had moved the structure
of the critical
point of the system
from the phase
diagrams one to five.
And the transitions can
be seen to be smooth
if you had a continuum
of values for c.
So that ends this recitation.